c'était il ya dix ans jour pour jour le
17 décembre 2010 du côté de sidi bouzid
dans le centre de la tunisie à mohamed
bouazizi vendeur ambulant de fruits et
légumes s'immole par le feu après s'être
fait confisquer sa marchandise par des
policiers est cet acte désespéré de ce
jeune homme de 26 ans et déclencheur du
printemps arabe
s'ensuivra des semaines de
manifestations marquées par des émeutes
sanglantes aux quatre coins du pays
une colère dirigée contre le président
au pouvoir depuis 23 ans avec pour seul
mot d'ordre benali dégage mais c'est
inadmissible on en a plein le cul de lui
de ses conneries on veut qu'ils dégagent
qu'ils dégagent meert qu'il dégage est
que nos prêts et que les prisonniers
d'opinion dans cet établissement même
derrière vous qu'ils sont libérés ils
sont entrain aux socios de se faire
torturer
pourquoi parce qu'ils se sont exprimés
franchement on veut que benali qui te
pouvoir au moins 338 morts et plus de
2000 blessés
cette révolution du jasmin comme on se
plaît à la qualifier a eu raison du
président ben ali qui prendra la fuite
le 14 janvier 2011
mais qu'en est il aujourd'hui que
reste-t-il des espoirs qui avaient
émergé à l'époque une révolution prend
du temps et elle est souvent semée
d'embûches en politique par exemple la
tunisie a connu en une décennie 9
exécutif dans certains n'ont tenu que
quelques mois encore aux la difficulté
de s'entendre pour les deux forces
politiques majeures du pays laïcs et
islamistes
le dernier gouvernement date est celui
dit chen li shishi ancien ministre de
l'intérieur
approuvé en septembre par le parlement
il est composé de juges d'universitaires
de fonctionnaires et de cadres du privé
je suis fier de ce soutien le
gouvernement va pouvoir avancer sur les
problèmes économiques du moment qu'ils
ne se retrouvent pris dans aucun
tiraillements politiques et des
problèmes économiques la tunisie en
collectionne depuis dix ans la
croissance a diminué de
moitié depuis 2010 le chômage pointes à
plus de 16%
il est endémique chez les jeunes
puisqu'ils représentent 85 % des
demandeurs d'emploi le dinar la monnaie
tunisienne a perdu 40% de sa valeur et
la dette du pays a quadruplé elle
atteint désormais 100 milliards de
dinars soit plus de 30 milliards d'euros
la pandémie de kobe 19 a fini par mettre
l'économie tunisienne à genève martin
autres le terme
on est tous fatigués pourquoi parce que
tout à augmenter les conditions de vie
sont plus difficile qu'il ya dix ans
arles a fait une révolution pour abords
du mieux on a le pire
tout a augmenté c'est devenu difficile
pour nous on n'en peut plus notre
salaire arrive et il repart aussi vite
on s'en rend même pas compte notamment
de la liberté à l'extérieur tu sens
qu'il ya eu du changement avec le
système avec town chose tu la sens la
liberté mais elle m'a servi à rien on
pense qu'à partir quitter le pays ce
qu'on a entendu pendant la révolution
il n'en est rien ressorti pas de travail
pas de liberté en farsi la liberté n'est
pas de la liberté liberté plus une
liberté 200 vols ce qui compte c'est la
liberté du citoyen c'est travailler moi
je suis au chômage situation tout aussi
compliquée sur le plan social face à la
flambée des prix le centre et le sud du
pays connaissent régulièrement de vue
hantée meute pour tenter de mieux vivre
de survivre
des dizaines de milliers de tunisiens
tentent chaque année de rejoindre
l'europe souvent au péril de leur vie
alors si la plupart des tunisiens estime
aujourd'hui être plus libre que sous
l'ère ben ali
le sentiment de déception et d'amertume
reste très présent chez ceux qui
attendait bien mieux d'une démocratie